موقف محمود محمد طه من قضية الصلاة،
أحالني على قصّة معروفة في أقطارنا المغاربية،
تتعلّق بسيدة تقية متقدمة في السن تدعى ميمونة،
هذه السيدة كانت لا تحفظ القرآن ولا تعرف تفاصيل طُقس الصلاة كما حدده الفقهاء،
فكانت تقيم صلاتها وتتعبّد بطريقتها الخاصة،
فعند سجودها كانت تردد عبارة "ميمونة تعرف ربي وربي يعرف ميمونة"،
الناس من حولها لم يقبلوا طريقتها في أداء الصلاة،
واعلموا شيخ القرية بذلك،
هذا الأخير اخبر ميمونة ان صلاتها باطلة وغير سليمة.
ميمونة التي كانت تحب الله بصدق وتتقرّب له بطريقتها الخاصة،
حزّ في نفسها ردة فعل الشيخ والناس تجاهها،
فقررت الاعتكاف في منزلها، للتعبّد والصلاة بطريقتها التي تعودت عليها،
فعاد الناس من جديد للشيخ لإخباره ان ميمونة قاطعت الناس واعتكفت في بيتها،
ذهب الشيخ إلى منزل ميمونة،
ولاحظ غبطة المرأة وسعادتها وهي تتعبّد،
فأمر الناس أن يتركوها لحالها،
وخرج ولسان حاله يقول؛
"ميمونة تعرف ربي وربي يعرف ميمونة".
إذن كما قال محمود محمد طه الصلاة ليست غاية في ذاتها،
بل هي وسيلة للتقرّب من الخالق،
لذلك عندما تفقد جوهرها الروحاني،
تصبح مجرّد تديّن شكلاني.